separate job so
i apologize i'm having to take this
meeting from the town hall
if any of you in your meetings are
addressed by
airband and told what a wonderful
service they provide
i can vouch for the fact that i've been
off since friday morning
with no internet whatsoever
hence i'm in the town hall so item one
apologies for absence
[Music]
sorry chair i couldn't have mute um one
apology
counselor bright
anybody substituting no
okay
item two minutes of the cnr meeting
of the 7th of december pages 3 to 15.
uh reading i'm going to read from the
bottom
anyone wish to pick up any errors in it
first of all
page 3 4
5 6
7 8
9 10
11 12
13 14
and 15. are you all happy with those
that they should be signed as a true and
correct record we'll put it to the vote
please i propose that they're accepted
chancellor james uh propose
thank you second day council lock second
thank you chair
yes sorry i don't know if you did i was
on the phone to counsel my golf a second
ago did you go through apologies and say
there were no apologies
uh no we said there were apologies from
councillor bright
prime counselor right
there's also apologies from councillor
brenton
and councillor craigie um is
substituting charlotte sorry i was on
the phone trying to get council mcgoff
into the meeting
right everybody's having trouble this
morning with the sounds of it
welcome you councillor craigie
um right we're going to take a recorded
vote on the minutes
thank you
councillor bushby or
councillor christie
not present thank you tom
councillor james or
counselor laws
for
or councillor wiseman
or councillor craigie
um i better abstain i'm sorry because i
wasn't here
thank you councillor craigie
okay uh anyone wish to comment on
anything
proper job right we move on to
item three the action
list on page 16.
there's a few things there
are you going to take the first one
steve
yes thanks thanks trey um i've since
only the first item i've since had
an email from council bushby who ray
originally raised the notice of motion
uh kind of saying it's it's not worth
progressing
at this time
[Music]
and um would withdraw the motion
right um obviously we've obviously been
trying to get
information from other authorities but
much like ourselves most authorities
are kind of dealing with the response
that pandemic so i know we've had
difficulty
uh getting those responses and obviously
we're looking at
other works around grounds maintenance
and so forth so i think
i know council bushby's part c
considered
it's not considered it not being
progressed
at this time
you confirm that counselor bushby
yes sir yeah i do confirm that thank you
are you any more on the action list
steve
sorry chair is there any more on the
action list i'm
looking any other item was the
environment center
um which councillor bushby asked for a
copy of the original report back in 2017
uh which has been forwarded so again if
council bushby can
confirm he's had that report
was it sent electronically steve
um sandra tom do you know
please um the only
sorry the only thing that i do know
about it is i think richard
it was left with richard haste to
forward it
um i'm not sure whether it was
electronically
it was kirsty that had spoken to richard
no case i haven't okay we'll make we'll
make sure it's sent
electronically um this week
the council should be done i'll chase
that up
chair proper job
should we move on item for public
contributions
i've got no record of anything
nor is anyone else so we can move on to
item five
five the forward plan page 17 i think it
is
you've got it there anyone wishing to
comment there too
i've got nothing to add here nope proper
job
who will be finished early at this rate
um item seven
uh six declarations of interest
you're all grown up you know the score
i'm not gonna go into it
members of the public may like to be
aware that
members if they have a they or their
family
have a pecuniary or
personal interest in anything it has to
be declared
publicly and they do not take part in
that item
item seven agreement of the agenda
between parts one and two
i don't think there's anything for part
two
so we move right on item eight
urgent matters i've got nothing have you
got anything steve
uh no chair robert job
item nine update on the team devon
covid 19 economic business recovery
program
pages 18 to 41. steve that's you i guess
i want to be taking that one okay
thank you chair um so so it gives me a
pleasure to present to you the work of
last summer
that we did in conjunction with devon
county council from the other devon
districts to prepare the
economic and business recovery program
that's attached to the report
obviously when covid pandemic first
struck
the first thoughts were around our
initial response to how we deal with
things
and we went into response mode
but immediately we were also thinking
about how do we bounce back from this
and the team devon approach was was uh
pulled together so that we took a
consistent view of this across
devon working with the uh other partners
we we produced a document that has four
core areas which concentrates on our
people
our businesses places and the
opportunities that might be presented
off the back of the pandemic and also
there's a recognition in the document
that there are three
core time frames restart which is
getting back on a feat
regrow and reset and those are set out
in the report
i think probably it's the most
relevant parts of this as uh for us are
set out in
in the conclusions in the report uh the
the document that's attached was
actually adopted by the county council
back in september of last year and
they've been working on many of the
actions
within it as have we we just have no
chance to report anything
to you yet um but in the five bullet
points
uh in the report of the next steps uh we
intend to produce a prospectus
of projects and this is in line with the
sort of getting things shovel ready
so that we're in a good position to
exploit opportunities and we'll do that
in partnership with others
uh we work with north devon council and
the lep
on the build back better proposals the
leader and i were actually in a meeting
on friday council hudson was there as
well
um and the the importance of a
coordinated response to the buildback
better lep
program was very much at the top of the
agenda
um we'll deliver the projects that we've
already got underway that have been
supported by the laps so we'll
concentrate our efforts on
on doing those like the borough centre
um and work with the biosphere
we'll produce business support proposals
so as part of the additional
restrictions grant
we are innate we're able to retain um
as much of that fund as we wanted for
long-term business support but it's
intended that we will
retain a smaller amount um
but a report will come back to to this
committee about those proposals at a
later date
i wouldn't think too far away because we
need to get some plans in place
and we'll work in partnership with the
heart of the southwest leb
to deliver the ambitions setting the
coastal productivity plan
um happy to take any questions chair
okay anyone wishing to speak
okay you've got councillor christian
councillor lock with their hands up
ah right i've got nothing showing on my
screen
councillor christie please thank you yes
um very interesting plan uh a couple of
things i i did pick up which struck me
is slightly odd
on page 19 of our agenda
you've got these three marvelous
headings restart regrow and reset
um under regrow the first line there is
talking about seeking to bring forward
actions which will allow business and
communities
to return to the status quo
then reset actions to change now
directly contradictory um i'm not sure
how you can have the status quo and
change everything at the same time
i wonder because i read this and it
talks about under reset
it talks about uh return economically
bigger
better and bolder than when the crisis
began
and i wonder if we shouldn't look to
retrench
what we've got at the moment because we
have existing problems from
our economy and it's no good just saying
ah we're going to make it bigger and
better
um i mean we've got problems like
seasonality
in our economy we've got our low wages
which i see is referred to
and even simple things like potholes
which don't seem to happen and i wonder
if we shouldn't
rather than just you know get talking
about we're going to become economically
bigger
we've got a chance to re well to
readdress our entire way of life
we don't often get that because lockdown
has completely derailed everything
and i wonder if rather than just say oh
we're going to come back and be bigger
and better
we should actually be looking at what we
do
well at the moment what should we
address at the moment
because we already have problems it's no
good creating new stuff
i mean it's only my opinion but it is a
chance we have i think
to actually look again at our way of
life
right anyone wishing to comment to that
chair you've got three hands counsellor
councillor bush being counseling
i'm sorry for some reason my screen
isn't showing me who is looking to speak
uh counselor lock yeah well mine's not
such an
in-depth uh query as as what council
christie's was
mine is on page 21 bulletproof point
three either i've missed it or i've
forgotten can something please explain
what the smart
biosphere pilot project is please
chair i can say that one quickly if you
like so there are a range of different
initiatives being worked on
by the biosphere worked up by the
biosphere
so they were looking at a digital pilot
scheme they're looking at an
investment scheme there's the smart
uh biosphere which is around gathering
all of the digital information
and making it accessible within the
borough within the
biosphere and also about making sure
that it's carbon capture
and even the sale of carbon credits and
at the biosphere so
it's a it's quite an innovative um
project that's being worked on it's been
looked at
um so far in in these very early stages
quite positively by the lap and others
um it's something that is very relevant
to the area and coming back on
cancer christie's earlier point it's
something that is perhaps
uh resetting our priorities locally as
opposed to
uh looking to traditional in sort of
industry
it's looking at how we might uh use the
uh
current um climate emergency to actually
drive our local economy uh so so that
that's that in a nutshell it's quite
it's
well it's quite complex i could send you
some documents if you'd like
so as a council we haven't actually
discussed it hasn't been brought back to
tdc yet no no thank you
chancellor bushby
thank you chair um page 18 the
fourth paragraph down the last sentence
it says for some sectors such as tourism
and hospitality
the journey back to levels of income and
employment experience in
2019 may take a decade
to recover um
so i mean that's a fairly depressing
state uh statement to uh to acknowledge
but um
i don't think you're probably uh far off
off the offer mark with that
so i mean what are top what are torrids
um
what what are we then as taurus going to
do to trying to help that sector
um you know to recover you know quicker
um
i um you know things like planning and
things
that you know affect any issues with
regard to
hospitality and tourism i mean are they
going to be looked at
favorably
chair would you let me come back on that
one yes please
so um so i think it's a i think it's a
very valid point
cancer bushby i think um we need to
and again it goes back to to the points
made by council christie earlier look at
what our local priorities are and decide
what we want to do
we're going to be producing this
prospectus of projects that will
try to cover off those hardest hits
or those places where there's the most
opportunity and present those
opportunities to the left so i would
imagine
quite a lot of initiatives that we put
forward um and obviously there'll be
a chance for members to discuss those
those proposals before they're presented
will include something for tourism when
it comes to looking at
uh planning policy that's something that
will be wrapped up within the local plan
review and i'm
fairly certain that our members on the
local joint local plan working group
will have tourism at the front of their
minds and how we might support
that sector of the economy in the future
at the moment we're kind of stuck with
the uh policies that we've got
but we we obviously work around them to
get the best effects
and i think moving forward in the next
couple of years is a chance to influence
those things quite a lot but
obviously we've got some members of the
local planned working group on the call
today
you might have comment on that thank you
good to hear counsellor
laws thank you thank you chair
well there is one thing for for a
certainty
uh life is going to be very different
when we come out at the other end
uh i mean just today listening to the
news this morning
we've just got two major high street
chains
that have have now gone down that's
25 000 jobs gone
now that's going to be reflected in our
high streets
i'm afraid uh and um
this whole thing has accelerated
online and i think the greatest thing
that torridge could do
it's almost back to the hub in a way but
we have to go
out to uh business people and really try
to help them
um market their businesses online
whether it's farm fresh sausages
in my case fishing tackle clothing
we're going to have to every field
has to now have an online presence or
it's dead in the water
and i think we have to go out to our
communities and try to help them
it's no just use creating a website
you've then got to find the ways to
market that website
and i know it's i know it's depressing
and i know our high streets
for a time will probably look shabby
until they adapt
but if they go online these all of those
shops
can still be trading in in five or ten
years time
if they fail if we don't help them
to go online we're going to have dismal
high streets here
you need you need the shops you need the
tourism
it all has to be tied together your
tourism
they already bring in all their bookings
online
now we've got to find a way of getting
the businesses to bring
their income in online thank you chair i
know it
sounds over easy and over simple but i'm
sure you get the message
thank you councillor bushby
thank you chair but in response to what
council laws have said i'm
i tend to agree with them but i think
the chamber of commerce are the
or the body that has the expertise to um
you know to help uh traders get online
so my advice would be
for councillor law to encourage all
businesses
to become a member of the general
commerce which is free for this year
um they they offer a range of packages
which
um you know which varies in expertise
and you know input from the chamber but
um
online presence is certainly you know
one of the things that they
can help on and can't help significantly
sean thank you chair yeah just just to
very quickly come back to cancer laws
much of what council laws um has uh
said has been discussed in in the team
development meetings i think there's a
recognition of
of the points that he's making there are
very accurate
um the the importance of town centers
the re-purpose in the town centers
and the experience people expect or
would like
or we can deliver for them it is
picked up within the places section of
the report so there's a
there'll be a strong town centre strand
within that across the county i suspect
we can strengthen that as much as we
like locally and i think
our continuing work on the uh trying to
find a way to deliver the biddeford
future high street proposals in the
globe in torrent
are examples of how we'll try and do
that the the legacy
side of this and the advice and the
business bit can be picked up under
the um 0.4
where we will have some funding that we
can retain
and if businesses are needing advice on
how to best
exploit the online opportunity so that
they keep your business going
we could develop some proposals around
that
thank you sean now according to my
screen i've got no one else wishing to
speak
and it is for noting this report
um with a commitment to
bring back further updates in due course
so i think it's a case of note it and
move on
okay item 10 play strategy
pages 42 to 64.
who's dealing with this one you've got
me again chair
so i'll try and keep this one brief
because i think everybody's reasonably
familiar with the
discussions that we've been having
around the play strategy and obviously
the draft strategies
is presented for you today we have for
some time been talking about
at the council uh the the importance of
play
and i i believe that uh members have
felt that we perhaps had a
a slightly uncoordinated approach to how
we deal with our player state
and so the uh the the urgency to put in
place a play strategy
has been there for some time and
unfortunately it's in its evolution
is taking a a couple of knockbacks and
kovitz certainly hasn't sped the process
up
um what we really want to do is to adopt
the strategy and then move forward with
the the overriding overarching strategic
ambitions within the strategy which are
to concentrate our
efforts and resources corporately on
those uh what we might consider to be
more strategic
play assets the larger areas that we
maintain for wider
hinterlands and then have discussions
about
what we do with the rest of our play
estate with interested partners within
the community
parishes um and community groups and
people like that
one of the next steps urgent next steps
is to finish the conditions survey that
we've got we've started on that we
haven't had chance
because of other priorities to to do
that but that will tell us exactly what
state of play
all of our play equipment is in and then
associated with that we will start to
talk to our communities
should you adopt strategy about their
ambitions in
and locally and we can then formulate
plans as to how we either
work with them to improve the estate or
we transfer
play areas to other communities and and
and things like that so
um i'm quite happy i'm over
ovie and scrutiny um have really given
this
a good going over a few times now
the recommendation is set out so they've
recommended that we
um adopt the strategy recommended to you
that we adopt strategy
subject to changes the changes have been
made within the report by adrian avery
who's
actually pulled all this together for us
but they've also
talked about the need to set up an
allocated budget
now obviously budget discussions have
been picked up separately we've got
those going on
and they move towards our final budget
setting
we haven't made a strong recommendation
to you one way or the other there on
this
i think that the long and short of it is
in referencing our other discussions
we don't have the funds unless we
de-prioritize something else to create a
specific play budget
and we should perhaps look at our
priorities on a
site-by-site basis and work out how they
should be funded moving forward
we do obviously have within our
responsive maintenance budget
the sort of funding that we need to
repair our play equipment and we also
have some already set aside in the
capital programme for place so
um i just present to you the
recommendations from ons and for you to
consider
thank you
thank you right i've got a string of
members wishing to speak
um i haven't got them in priorities so
i've started doing it alphabet
counselor bushby
uh thank you chair um a question for
sure if i could a couple
please um i see on page 56 there's a
list of
um i'm on page 57 a list of all the
parks that we've got
and i see that the burden green park in
bedford
doesn't appear on the list at all
that's the first question yeah it's not
one of ours councillor bushby it belongs
to westwood housing
really okay
the second question um
which i'm pretty sure the answer will be
similar to that one
but at least the water up at biddy back
biddy
black way um there is a
quite a substantial partner in in
reasonably good condition with a bugger
with various other bits and pieces of
equipment there
and i understand um the developer
who developed the site has offered this
offered the site
offered the playground to um to torridge
and
you've turned it down
i'm chair i can respond if you like
uh i i'm not aware of that counselor
bushby
it it wouldn't surprise me if that were
the case though because
our current approach to this is not to
adopt
extra play areas they tend to come with
extra maintenance liabilities and we're
really struggling to meet the ones we've
got
yeah well the reason i asked the
question because
uh and i also as a tenant counselor
wearing that hat
you know we've been approached by the
tanker so we've been approached
as the town council to see whether we
would be interested in taking it over
well you know clearly you know as a
small tanker so we
you know we also don't have the
resources to be able to
um you know take on something like that
certainly not without
a substantial dowry that went with it um
i mean this is something that torridge
could pursue with the
you know with the developer i'm not
talking about taking it on for nothing
but take it on with a substantial cash
payment so that
at least it pays for you know the
upgrade of equipment
um you know going forward for the next
you know 10 years or whatever
or or indeed ask them to replace all the
equipment so that everything in there is
is new so that you've got you know a
level playing field if you pardon the
pun
right from the start so that it is all
new because
you know my my problem here is that
someone has to take responsibility
for this playground it's very well used
and it is a good a really nice
playground
and i i did go up and have a visit there
and
you know easter water the the estates
around that area are growing
you know ever larger and that park is
only going to be more and more popular
so you know someone has to take
responsibility and if the developer
you know clearly as they always do they
want to walk away from these things
if they're not going to accept
responsibility i would have thought
the the obvious candidate would be the
district council
so i would say i would ask them you know
you look at this again and see whether
you can do a deal with
the developer and so a way forward can
be found to take it over
um from the chair i would say councillor
bushby
i fully sympathize with your view
looking at it from the town council
point of view
go out in the rural areas torridge has
no play areas they are all either owned
by the paris councils
or the village playing field committee
now why in the rural areas can we
organize it for ourselves
and yet we come into the towns and you
want torridge to pay
if we follow through your logic then you
can take over all the playing fields out
in the rural areas yeah
well that's a good point yeah either
largely the rural the rural uh settings
are
you know much easier to maintain it's
usually a grass field and a
you know a few um you know a few bits of
equipment
but yeah and i take your point i think
all of these play areas are
better managed um by
you know being looked after by local
communities and if that's
you know parishes and things like that
um you know so much the better
but because this is such a large um play
area
i mean presumably when it was given
planning permission it was
it went through torrid so you know
there's a degree of responsibility there
but i just go back to what i say you
know it's a it's a fairly large play
right with a lot of a lot of equipment
including a mugger you know with you
know basketball
um hoops and everything like that you
know
someone at some point is going to have
to look after it i don't see the
residents taking it on
uh and without a substantial payment
they don't see that just
basically all i'm saying well there we
are right we'll move on to other members
counselor dart
thank you chair i've just got to ask
is this the play strategy that costs
torridge
from memory ten thousand pounds a lot
more now
yes check yes that did counselor dart is
referencing discussions that we had
um probably 18 months ago now where we
uh where we ask for a budget to uh to
to progress as
oh well dark do you want to come back
can i come back chair
yep yes please
um so bear in mind this
few pages cost us ten thousand pounds
and essentially what i'm
taking from this document is
the recommendation that
heartland parish council take on the
heartland
um play area i don't know about any
other rural areas but
councillor hicks you've just said that
tourists don't own many
rural play areas i know they don't own
bravery because they handed that back
um but i reckon there are some rural
players
that torridge still have responsibility
for essentially in this report it
recommends
handing them over to whoever will take
them presumably
and it also recommends
a fencing strategy is that gonna cost us
another 10 000 pounds
um and also then
essentially torridge needs to keep the
larger players
and prioritize well yeah i could have
done that for ten thousand pound i could
have written that down
it's not rocket science i just find that
quite a lot of money for
not a lot of rocket science
here i can respond to that if you like
this please
so so we did pay uh tivoli actually to
do some some work for us that the money
that we've spent with tivoli wasn't
necessarily
all related to the production and
strategy some of that did come into the
production strategy
but behind siddha strategy was a whole
lot of condition surveys work that's
been done
simply needs updating now because it was
done towards the middle of
um well early part of 2020 i think now
so
we you know before we start making
decisions on different spaces we need to
have that current that was where the
lion's share of what that budget went
um i'm not recommending to see you today
that we we prepare a fencing strategy
and i won't be asking for any funds
towards that
but councillor dart is right that the
overriding ambition is to concentrate
what resources we have
on those uh larger play areas and work
with communities so it won't mean in
every instance you transfer
out to play area there might be other
solutions where we work in partnership
with the parishes
or community groups to raise funds
to deliver um improvements so
uh that's why we've got adrian avery in
the team he's a community engagement
officer and it would form a big part of
his work moving forward
counselor christie thank you
um well the place strategy has been
quite some time in
gestation hasn't it taken a long time to
get here
um i want to go come back to biddeford
obviously a bit of a member
uh after the last elections in may 2019
um i became the mayor of biddeford and
one of my first things i did was to
put a motion to the town council that uh
we
we give 25 000 pounds towards to
torridge
to update the play equipment in
biddeford
i managed to match fund that from the
british trust
so it was 000 pounds there for torridge
uh in the 20 months since then torridge
has managed to spend
5 000 pounds uh putting some new
equipment in one place
and i'm just astonished i've just heard
sean say
you know we've got to spend our money
wisely um
there's 45 000 pounds just sitting there
doing nothing
um can we spend it fairly quickly
because
it sits in the bridge trust budget and
it sits in the town council budget doing
absolutely nothing it's just
sterile money um obviously it's ring
fence for biddefords so i don't want
councillor hicks getting excited about
buckland brewer
um it is ring fence for biddeford and
the idea was it would uh add to what
torres is going to spend it
isn't uh there to replace what torres
was going to spend in biddeford
but it's uh in addition because as
council hicks has pointed out
the parishes do their bit towards play
area here in beautiful we've done our
bit as well
so could i ask that uh we do spend it
fairly quickly thank you
sean do you want to come back yeah yeah
thank you uh
thank you councillor christie that's
great it's great news obviously i've
been aware that
the budget's been set there one of the
things i i guess we mustn't forget is
that the last 12 months has been
particularly difficult
and actually things like play areas have
probably become second best to some of
the more
acute and emergency responses you've had
to make in terms of covid so a lot of
resources been directed that way
the other thing i think we've got to be
realistic about is we haven't had a
community engagement officer for a long
part of that period
we have recruited one now he's up to
speed and he's doing a great job
like i say i think it's the sort of
thing that he he will be able to
work with the communities to make uh to
spend those
um funds i think moving forward what
we've got to do is we've got to move
away
from uh the opportunity for other
organizations to provide us with lists
of to-do's
and work more actively in partnership
with these organizations
so it's great that funds are available
we do need to understand
local priorities and i think we need to
find solutions because actually we do
struggle to resource
delivering everything for everyone
thank you council of laws
yeah thank you chair uh a chair
um i'm a great supporter of
of of play and uh
i was a great supporter of this play
strategy but it's it's
been outdated already i'm afraid in the
sense that
the call on our budget here is
colossal man i don't know how
steve can sleep at night sometimes and
we are not
as i understand it required it's not
play
is not a straight it's not our
technical responsibility
we look at the local area here
biddeford there we've heard fifty
thousand pounds
northern taken over all the parks in our
parish applesaur northam and now
westwood hope
their responsibility torridge do
have one play park in in westwood which
was new a couple of years ago i think it
was about 50 or 60 000 pounds
we have to cut our cloth chairman
i think the smaller parishes
uh they they will need a bit of help
they'll need they'll need some
money to go with it but i think we just
have to lose these responsibilities of
all the small parts
bit of a town might well want to go in
further
when they when they when they see the
logic that torridge just cannot keep
funding this and i just think we just
have to hand it
hand the responsibilities over um
it's working well in normal it works
well
i'm in in biddeford as far as it could
go torrington
was a councillor there that i believe
wanted a play park desperately and got
it
i'm not sure the british precision the
provision in whole sweaty
but chair i think it's time we moved on
i think our officers have bigger bigger
fish to fry
thank you
councillor locke yeah good luck to come
back on councilx's
point about rural areas i in my own
village of dolson we've got a
really really big and well-equipped play
park
right in the middle of the village which
paris council worked really hard to
maintain
and they also owned a football pitch
which we maintained
and in b third beaver barrage council
has strived the last three years
and have just managed to get all new
equipment by fundraising and applying
for
external grants so i just think it's
absolutely vital
that even the town play parks do the
same
and character christie talks to 45 000
pounds available
but in reality he's probably only talked
about two pieces of equipment
i know in dalton we just replaced the
surface
uh the safety service under one biggest
equipment and that cost nine thousand
pounds
just for a safety surface under one bit
of equipment so 45 000 pounds
in reality doesn't go very far
just one point can someone explain to me
the subtle difference between
poor and needs attention
what's the difference in those two
categories
the chair i can't tell you with any
certainty i'd have to refer back to the
people who produced the report i'm
afraid
i'd be interested to know there's
something different special
yeah counselor bushby
uh thank you chair um well clearly
victoria park in bedford is
is the jewel in the crown and as much as
parks in the
in the different area um and
historically it's always been
a fantastic park um over the last
10 years or so you know we've seen a
steady decline in
you know the quality of the of the
provision i'm not talking just
just play equipment but the general
overall appearance of the park has just
got worse and worse and worse
so you know i don't think that comes as
any surprise to anyone
and i would love to see it's always been
an ambition of mine for the town council
to be in a position where we could
take over uh the victoria park in its
entirety
um you know it's a personal ambition of
mine um
but you know clearly if if torrids are
serious about
wanting to divest some of these
these assets to uh you know parishes in
the community
you know that's where i'd i'd love to
see something start there but clearly
we would have to sit down and have a
good discussion about
exactly uh the way forward in terms you
know financially because
you know that but the part must cost
storage
you know tens of thousands of pounds
annually
um you know going forward um
if it did if a deal could be done i'd
love to be able to put that to
the count council uh with uh councillor
christie's help
uh and councillor mcguff who's here as
well all better north councillors
i mean we could do a fantastic job but
it would have to come with the necessary
you know finance to it to
support it at least for a few years
anyway
sure yes sir thank you chair so so i
must say that
that is um slightly contra to the
ambition of this strategy in that this
strategy would guide us towards
concentrating our efforts on assets like
uh
victoria park in biddeford by divesting
ourselves
of uh things that take resource
elsewhere so
what we might do again because i've come
back to this i've said it several times
today it's about working in partnership
it might be that
without taking ownership the town
council could supplement the activity of
the
district um to improve the space there
that's something we could definitely
discuss
and also members are aware that we you
know we we are
in constant discussions
about our grand maintenance arrangements
and we might be able to look for future
improvements there so
um i'd be happy to talk to the tankers
about that but this strategy actually
wouldn't
lead us to a natural conclusion to
transfer out
uh victoria park as an asset
chancellor james i thank you chair
i'll just say with holdsworthy area i
know of no
play areas that are owned by torridge i
see on the list
there's one called woodside which i
don't know i know woodside the
development
and it's fairly recent so i'm assuming
that was a part of 106 developer
put in whether we're responsible for it
or not i'm not sure
um and obviously
we do in the rural areas just get on
with it and pray that's
the way of the world um i like the look
of victoria park i
i won't do it down but obviously we're
looking at supporting biddeford
um and not the rural areas
if we come to the recommendations i
don't see that we can actually maintain
a budget for play areas at this time
because it's going to be a big argument
about how much money we put to it
but i'm quite happy to to support the
recommendation and propose the play area
strategy
is accepted um adopted
at this time thank you chair
thank you i'll take that as a proposal
yeah i'll just see if i've got a
seconder to it at the moment
i will second that counts a lot thank
you
right we'll now move on councillor
craigie
speaking as a member of committee not as
a guest to be precise i believe
thank you chair um i just i'd just like
to
agree with quite a lot of what's been
said already
um i agree with councillor dart that
really i was hoping for a lot more than
this i was hoping for a strategy
about the whole area and how we provide
for all age groups
and make sure that we've got the right
provision in the right areas
and the whole strategy on play in actual
fact is just a
you know how can we cope with getting
rid of it
i agree with councillor bushby
wholeheartedly
that biddeford would absolutely love to
take over
the um the play areas and we could we
could do a really
good job with it i'm quite sure but we
haven't got the money so
i think if you're going to move this on
i
i would say with a proviso that yes we
could move
we need to move this play strategy on
because we've been stuck for so long
it's been absolutely ridiculous no
money's been spent because every time
you've asked for something
being told it's got to wait for the play
strategy
which is nearly two years now and i
point to
councillor dermots mcgoff's um
disabled swing we even had the finances
for that
with from the the town council and the
bridge trust and we still
haven't got it we haven't been given
permission to put it in
because this hasn't been moved forward
so i think we need to get on with it but
i would put a proviso we need a
financial settlement
and sean kearney has said there is the
money in the budget
for play i believe it's about 250 000
so i would suggest that we need each
um area like northern and biddeford and
any other area that's taking on a
substantial amount of play areas
we need a financial settlement and i
think until that's been agreed it's very
hard to to you know to move forward
so um i think i think we do need to get
on with it but let's
by the next cnr let's have a financial
strategy of how much each council is
going to be given
thank you so chip chair
yeah did i just clarify that there's no
um
suggestion that we would that we would
hand over funds to
parish or town councils um and just hand
over players i think what we need to do
is work
with them to understand the ambitions of
those localities
see what we own what they can bring to
the table where external funding is in
place and how we maximize our joint
efforts
it's not simply there's a piece of land
there's a few quid
it's it we would we would try to be a
bit more scientific
in in trying to get to what our
communities need than that
council mcguff
thank you very much mr chairman i
totally agree what counselor craig you
just mentioned a moment ago that
disabled swing
have any finances in place so exactly
turn the engine off
having the finances in place to go ahead
with it
i can see the complications that arise
with the safety element of the swing as
i've been told many a time but that's
easily resolved
if we touched on catching the bush bees
passionate comments earlier on obviously
victoria park being a flagship within
torridge we're not trying to get any
arguments between rural
and urban areas we understand that the
rural areas cope very well
but you've got smaller population within
biddeford and northern areas the
settlements here we've got the main
population venturage
literally within a couple of miles of
each other and it's paramount that
obviously some of these money goes from
torres to
maintain their own equipment that we've
got there which means
i think bush be alluded to about a
decade in decline
but we need to see this uplifted
and obviously the finance the time
counts are taking it on
not at the moment uh council don't catch
us at kearney sorry councillor kearney
offers to canada you you're a leader
obviously working in partnership yeah i
think that's the best way forward for a
bit of tank at his moment
is to work in partnership with torridge
with victoria park
should we actually then become on a
level even keel
if we're actually on page zero zero then
it's a great position of a bit of a town
council to take on responsibility of the
park
uh i know it's a great asset the tourist
and we wouldn't give it to town council
but if some way we could do some sort of
agreement with you
where we could obviously maintain most
of it ourselves you know the bloom of
the park used to be absolutely amazing
and i do thank our mayor uh council of
christie for the money he provided in
2019
it was a huge amount of money for one
man to be able to pull together
which was which was absolutely fantastic
and we just need to see it
actually invested back into bit of area
itself
i mean going forward accounts of dart
search on the report
there's nothing against our officers i
think the report's very poor
unfortunately i thought it's going to be
an independent person doing a report but
as a contractor that we already use
doing a report
nice a little bit more money in the back
pocket i think that way
for that contractor i don't believe
they've done a great job at a park
as you can see that's why we've asked so
many times now of changing the contract
i think it's on the way of doing so i
know i think it's paramount and we do
actually get on with it
i understand we've not had an officer
present for a while dealing with a play
strategy
it is a frustration in mind because the
disabled swing
i've got hundreds and hundreds of emails
about the disabled swing i want to see
it but in the
victoria park itself and one over
um east of water as well by pollyfield
i mean this is the way forward at the
moment and i don't agree with cancer
laws this thing about
trying to pass it away because the
health and well-being of children
is absolutely paramount especially in
these uncertain times through the
pandemic as well
the health of a child is second to none
and a mental well-being of a child
this is the future you know i want them
to look back in 20 years time at
us now and this counts as saying
actually they were proactive they're
trying to look after us and they gave us
good opportunity
thank you much thank you councillor
mcguff
uh council of laws yes i
just i just come back and make it quite
uh clear i am a huge supporter of
children and play
and in northam um which is a parish as
as any it is a priority and we put our
money where
our mouth is what worries me is the
condition of the play equipment that is
in torridge
which i suspect is pretty terrible i
mean
i'm not hiking back over the past here
but northern we actually
paid for a park and we got our park and
we didn't even have a safety date on the
kiddies play area
when we purchased it because all play
equipment is expensive
and we just really got to look at play
again i can i fear there's a lot
what we've said today is going to
initiate a lot more officer time
um and really we should progress if
if parish councils or or groups
[Music]
that want to support play parts come
forward and are willing to take a park
over
we should let them well that's my
feeling
because they will probably because it's
their one thing and they're
concentrating on it
they will do it well but if you go out
now and you look at the small play park
you say right
those four pieces of equipment well in
westwood ho park
every piece of equipment was in need of
replacing
end of life now that's the same with all
our parts
probably apart from victoria um and
and really come on eyes open counsellor
we're supposed to be trying to give a
steer here
to uh the officers and it's
a huge amount of mixed messages we all
care but our budget the calls on our
budget are just tremendous now
thank you chair councillor hudson
thank you very much mr chairman i'm not
a member of this committee but
thank you for allowing me to speak just
a quick
um thing for uh councillor locke
the definitions of requires improvement
and poor uh detailed and explained on
page 55
of the report it's about the level of
failings
so um that is on there so that was just
sort of something i'd spotted the issue
for me with regard to
[Music]
where this play strategy is going
the population obviously we've noted
councillor mcguff has said
the population is greater in biddeford
and northern
so we have a greater number of people
who can come together
to fundraise and to support than some of
the rural communities that manage to do
this quite successfully
so i would encourage this strategy
and for the adoption of it not with the
inclusion of budgets but a very clear
steer
of developing community
town and parish council partnerships
with
torridge to develop their parks
they are the communities they recognize
what kind of things that they want in
their parks
through consultation and i think the way
forward for this in the future because i
do
accept the fact we do need to have some
kind of
investment
are you frozen from me after some kind
of investment cancer hudson
nothing coming through
well i'm sorry we seem to have lost
councillor hodgson
i'm chair ah potential board yeah come
to four so i
don't know which button from the end
could i just have a minute or two on
this item
uh please i won't want to be a minute or
two today we've kicked it around long
enough
obviously i was very fortunate my top
priority
and it does go to prove if you've got
some committed counselors that can work
together what you can achieve and i
thank todd very much for their support
in sorting out upload play part which
was sadly
um off the radar with the two previous
counselors
um they should have done the job better
actually so it was a disgrace
but it's not solved i thank tori for
that and in particular
i would like to thank norman tone
councillor and in particular coach
haynes and edwards for their support
going forward
we i think we all agree localized
control is better
we will be suggesting and i will be uh
driving that
that northern know that outdoors in good
order is taking over
and run by northern i do believe in
local control thanks chair
okay right it's been pushed around a lot
by
external scrutiny we have
recommendations on page 45
i'm gonna put it to the vote twice
because there are two there the first
part of councillor
james's proposal is that the
maintenance budget be not allocated
and i'm going to put that to the vote
first
thank you chair councillor bushby
against councillor christie
sorry check i'm putting with order
hello yes sorry yeah i didn't know um
we are when we vote if we were vote
for we vote for or against the um
the uh the budget because you know
the way you worded it it's a bit
confusing i think
councillor james's proposal was that the
money be
not allocated right so if you vote for
you are not allocating money thank you
right we'll go back and start again
thank you chair councillor bushby
against
councillor christie thanks
cancer dart
abstain
councillor hicks four
councillor james or penciller laws
or penciller lock or
councillor mcgoff
i'm against councillor wiseman
and councillor craigie
against
five one two three four one
chair that's five four four
against and one abstention
oh a tight one right now we take the
second part of the recommendation
that the play strategy be endorsed
and move forward
chair is this to include the budget or
you take
no okay thank you
slander are you okay to take the vote
yeah sorry tom um councillor bushby
against councillor christy
i'm gonna abstain on the basis that if
you're not going to allocate any money
i'm not sure how you can take the
strategy forward
i'm abstaining counsellor dart
abstain councillor hicks
or councillor james
or councillor laws
or cancer lock or
pencil mcgough i'd certainly agree with
cancer christie abstine sandra
thank you councillor wiseman or
councillor craigie against
that's five four two against and
three abstentions chair
thank you right now we can move on i
think it's
item 11. which is
urgency procedures
i guess that that steve taking a desert
i'm not sure whether sean or stacy was
um
it's just a it's a report for for noting
in terms of two urgent decisions that
have been taken
in response to the government's need to
get
business grants out businesses
and and because they have some element
of discretion it falls as a cnr decision
but in order to expedite the quick
payment of those grants the urgent
decisions were taken
and are required to be uh reported
retrospectively to the next cnr meeting
which is today
i'll propose them to chair
half second i don't know whether i
should declare an interest because i've
received one of the grants
so i will declare an interest turn up
okay um
moved and seconded that we adopt these
can we put it to the vote please chair
you've got two hands
yeah so dark wishing to speak
yeah like counselling laws i too have
received some grant funding so i'll
abstain from this one
okay to the vote please
you chair councillor bushby or
council christie or
councillor doctor abstain councillor
hicks
or councillor james
or not laws abstention counselor lock
or pencil mcgolf
ball cancer wiseman
that's unanimous for two abstentions
chair
thank you we can now move on to item
12. councillor ford's notice of
motion this is jet skis and the slipways
glenn i'm over here
um thanks chair i'll keep this brief i
won't even bother if you don't mind
because hopefully
we're all capable of reading so i won't
bother going over the motion and if at
the
end of a debate or anytime you need any
additional information
uh if you could i'll be glad to you know
take any questions
or whatever briefly this is never a
battle
between and i will put the end up and
it's first time i've ever done this
i have spoken to a few coaches including
yourself roselock
i did however make sure that i was not
doing so under duress it was purely on a
late thing
came come from the officer reference
maybe it's a good thing that perhaps if
we do one for ecuador we do the same for
biddeford because it's not happened or
read biddeford this is a genuine concern
i've got
with substantial uh evidence and when i
use the word a plethora of evidence
i actually know how to spell it no the
origin know what it means so i'm quite
happy to be challenged i've got the
evidence
just to recap uh on a couple of things
because you might get legal challenges
for instance so one thing
before uh because stacy might get
obviously um
ask questions later and rightly so maybe
we ought to think
of wording for instance what i would
propose maybe three meet or a three and
a half meter
length of boats power of watercraft pwcs
under the power of inboard engines which
would include jet skis
are banned from april and if you wish to
carry out a bit of fur that's what
somebody else just suggests because
my intention is not necessarily to move
the problem however
the problem would be made less because
of the access
to the river there's a lot less at bank
and biddeford than what it is that
appleboro
uh and i do know what i'm talking about
um just to go add a few more things
about
safety which is not necessarily uh
anything we can do about the river
because we haven't got a resource to
police it but it is
our slip way and we can decide who uses
our flip way
a devil man recently a devil man and
miss lee was in dubai
first time on a jet ski sadly
dead and he's lost a four-month-old
child you know how tragic can you you
know
get recently a true successful
prosecution against somebody who just
you know kept breaking the rules
basically sticking two fingers up as the
point is where i can cut it
to add additional information to people
that don't know ecuador
um i know i could all cosplay i was
actually born probably conceived in a
boat born in a bungalow 20 meters from
after all life
my fault slip but then probably to roll
a boat before i can actually
walk another important issue you've got
a hotel there i've spent thousands which
have said in fact
millions over the last seven years you
haven't got this at bank end or any
other
launch site you've got a band an apple
band that plays regularly in the summer
all right we didn't last year but
hopefully things will get back to normal
if possible
do they want to be actually disturbed
you know when you've got 100 200 people
outside of the summer's evening by jet
ski firing up 20 meters away get your
tape measure out
everything i'm saying is fact a question
in the report only one thing because i
will say
um we've had lovely debates um me and
sean not saying we might have had a stat
in the past but we're both mcmahon
enough to play
one side my question in the report only
one thing where it almost
goes implies that appledore is more
sensitive area than biddeford i would
actually
negate i'm sorry i don't think it is but
we're not here to have a bun fight
basically all you've got to ask as well
does jet skis actually sit lovely in a
triple si site in a biosphere zone
i don't think so be honest
picking up a point just not about
players we you know not being um
necessarily certain things being um
sort of essential in budgets and all
that actually a slipway is not essential
we have got to come to a solution here
more signs for people not to read it's
not an option
that hasn't been happening i even spoke
to the uh
park warden yesterday morning at house
nine saying oh he hasn't there's a
preset
well he's actually been truthful there
you have been able to please it
we're gonna have to get a barrier or do
something i'd also
therefore suggest because there's other
users with bigger crowds it's also i got
pictures of them on regular cases
breaking the rules parking on the beach
parking on the slipway
the slipways apart apart the car park
that comes from wrong officer
so all this needs looking at and if it
means actually charging
people to go through the barrier i would
be quite happy you could
limit it to a hundred users under a
pound a year to start with let's get a
bit of income
because they've been flanking it even
local people have been floating it so
it's not
sort of the holiday maker or whatever
they you know the outsider against the
local
it's actually just going to total
free-fall we got to stop
i mean clubs for instance a good club
we've got to think about this is not an
easy notes emotion to deal with i accept
that
other local clubs perhaps that employee
people like
scaring whatever could have a discount
or something it's over for you it's easy
for me to say thank god i'm not on your
committee
carry on chair thank you
okay len thank you i'm gonna throw it
open
i've got no one wishing to speak at the
moment you frightened a lot of them then
ah here we go they're coming councillor
haines first
thank you chair for letting me be not a
member of the committee
um i have read um council ford's
statement with the agenda
and um he's talked to me several times
about the problems on
the um church fields he's
um an apple dog like cancer like me but
he lives in the village and he knows the
problems he's down there every day
um i i totally sympathize and concur
with what he's said
it's getting more more crowded at church
fields
last summer we saw that cars couldn't
get into the
car park because it was full up the jet
skis
and with their trailers uh right near
where the buses turned
there where people drive in there where
people walk
and it does seem to me that you know
they don't
that is a big problem really with jet
skis
but my concern is i'd like to ask what
happens about
boat owners who want to launch off the
slipway i mean presumably
we'd have to have some sort of
arrangement where they're catered for
um if there was some sort of barrier um
or if i missed the point i don't know
and the other thing is that bank ends
presumed
there should be some sort of
investigation about the feasibility of
of using that site as well i'm not quite
sure where the slip way is at bank owned
i'm afraid so
if it's near the bridge um if it's near
um uh i can't remember the name of the
lane whether there's a nursery school
we're
just um no no one here though no
no okay um so yeah
i still maintain that that would need
investigation so there's those two
points really how you'd sort of filter
out the jet skis but allow boats
and also looking at um bank end
thank you
thanks chair yeah i have every sympathy
with them
with the problem here um
but i've also got a few other
perspectives so
one of my first questions would be how
do
other areas manage to safely
control the use of jet skis um
you know other areas in devon um
have them you know they are
in one way they can be an asset they
could draw people in
um i know you know people are always
suggesting that
the estuary is one of our main assets
and actually could be
a real hub for sporting activities
so i've sort of got that in my head as
well
um and if we were to shut bank end
as well as apple door are we not
perhaps cutting off a particular asset i
just
i appreciate the health and safety
aspects and i know there are dangerous
things but i also think
you know if we go back to the report
that was the devon community
devon or whatever it is all the devon
together report at the beginning of this
cnr meeting
you know going forward from
now um we want to be
promoting our area promoting tourism
clean growth
protecting our environment protecting
the carbon footprint and reducing it
this all factors into this argument
and i think there's a whole bigger
picture here
and i appreciate where len's coming from
with the health and safety i get that
entirely and
you know it's really serious but also
there's a real
um there's a real asset that we
we need to look at the whole i feel
um yeah
counselor lock
um yeah i mean i've done a bit of
homework on this as well
um and on page
83 the final paragraph once on the water
we have no
powers so therefore we must control
these jet skis before they even go on
the water you know don't wait for them
to go in the water and cause trouble
i mean with regards to signage i don't
think it matters
how big or how many signs that you put
in place
um the minority will always spoil it for
the majority i mean that
works in several aspects of life um if
we did close bank end as well
where else would be pushed into i mean
where else along our estuary
would they be able to launch their jet
skis or would they make some other you
know
sliding down the banks so i'd like an
answer to that
um and on page 86 the bottom paragraph
um they talk about the torah and torah
estuary forum
of which we are members if we had any
reports back from them or talk to them
about the problems of jet skis
i mean as things stand i mean i also
picked up about the devil man who
died in dubai um and brighton and hove
have got
trouble and they're looking to how to
ban jet skis and also in timbuth
so it's not just in apple door the apple
door estrella is country-wide
um but i'd like to know perhaps council
the fall can answer my question
if we close avatar and bank end
where would we push them to along the
history please
yeah yeah go on yeah yeah uh thanks for
that counselor lock um
yeah basically at the moment from our
own uh website
which is why again i'm reiterating it
was never
a suggestion at all that i was
suggesting that pushing the bit of it
i'm just saying at the moment
we can launch as it said from my report
we can launch at velator bounty in
castle key
barnstable and bank and benefit other
than appledore
now it's great and you can see this
point uh pencil like i'm sure that
it's all well and good now when i've got
all the problems down at appledore
and nobody else seems to matter you know
give her monkeys well
i can't stand hardly buying i think you
would at least respect me even though
we've had differences in the past
not to stand udly by because i will not
be
a status quo cannot be allowed uh
counselor lock um i think we
hopefully agree on that and all i'm
simply saying no matter what happens
today
i've tried my damn this and i probably
have lost sleep
overnight he almost made myself ill
because i do witness it on a daily basis
and i'm like i will be like pontius
pilate if this is left alone my hands
will be clear of blood
but this is how serious i'm taking this
and it's not been threatening
you know that's where it is there are
other things and if we can come with a
strategy
other bugs need to launch but even those
people
have been abusing it i've witnessed i
got the pictures endlessly
i've got pictures and pictures of it
let's try to make some money because
we can't put a barrier up for nothing
we've got little money at torrance we
just said that earlier
but we got to come to some solution and
i was repeat again
i'm the lucky one the other day looking
at you counselors because
it's you they've got to make the
decisions that's rather easy for me i
know thank you very much
all right councillor christie thank you
well yes i
recognize uh the problems in apple dawn
they are fairly serious
um however that is an ecuador problem i
i'm the councillor for biddeford i know
because ben king keeps coming up
uh bank end of course is you know we do
have a very large housing estate
just close to it and i would not like to
see
lots of jet skiers turning up and
launching off of bank end
and there is one other point which i
don't think councillor ford has
quite cottoned onto or other councillors
come to that
bank end is actually within the
biddeford harbour
area and the harbour board have control
of that
and of course this goes back to the
long simmering problem over does the
harbour board
control torridge or torres control the
harbour board
um the harbour board i think has the
right to ban
anything going in the river within the
harbour and that would overrule torridge
so
it would have to go to the harbour board
anyway um i've always found it odd that
uh jet skis zoom up and down the stream
what is
well it's a triple si to start with
we also have the london vessel going off
we have ships coming into
biddeford harbour we have the yacht club
we have appledore shipyard all going on
in the estuary and yet if you look up
the river
towards barnstable there's nothing in
the tour
estuary and i wonder if we shouldn't
actually approach
north devon and say look we've got jet
skiers
we could find somewhere to launch them i
don't know where from
but the torah estuary is empty the torah
gesture is full
and i've really never quite understood
why the jet skiers need to zoom up and
down to biddeford
thank you
right sean thank you chair does that i
got a world of things to answer here am
i so
um right in the first point i can't
remember which case i made it was around
physical barriers i can't see another
way for us to manage this and by
other than some physical barrier at the
slipways
if you decide to ban um the reason
the rationale behind not concentrating
solely on church fields was that
if you allow it at bank end and pick up
on councillor
ford's point that the tidal window
for launching at bank end is much less
than it would be at ecuador the
conditions for launching
are more difficult at bank end because
of the mud um
the problem comes down this way um
other landing sites yes there are and we
would have absolutely no control of
somebody come
launching from anywhere else and coming
into the estuary
um there's always been this voluntary
code of conduct because there aren't the
appropriate
rules and regulations to manage the on
river problem um other places do it by
bylaw
but then you have to resource that with
policing because what's the point of a
bylaw if you're not going to
enforce it and so if you took um
chairman you asked me to have paul the
harbour master
talk to falmouth and see whether there
was an issue down there
he's actually spoken to a number of
different harbour masters and it is an
issue
everywhere last year year before last
few years
uh jet skis has become ever more popular
there are more
everywhere there are probably less
responsible users
everywhere and it's become a problem
that people are finding very difficult
to manage
down there they do have bylaws in place
in torbay especially bylaws in place and
they actually have people patrolling the
harbor and a rib
that they pay to do that we wouldn't
propose to do anything like that here it
would cost us a fortune
um it's probably easier to just ban the
problem and i think that's the sort of
point i'm
trying to get to in in in the report
whilst trying to keep it balanced
because
as council of dan says there are some
positive aspects of this they
you know these people do holiday in the
area these people do spend in the area
when they're here it is part of the
attraction that makes us
um attractive to other places uh to
to people from other places um the
tortoise gesture forum yes
torture registry forum have for many
years been concerned about the use of
jet skis
and uh i haven't spoken to them in the
last few months but uh i'm sure they
will
only have gotten more upset about it
last year given that we had more users
than ever before
the harbour board uh have representation
on on the tortora gesturing
forum and the voluntary code of conduct
that was put in place was put in place
in consultation and as a partnership
with the hardboard
the biosphere reserve and they came to
the preferred zone for use
is uh downstream of the
new bridge nearly as far as say
the the shipyard the upper door shipyard
and that's the water sports zone where
people should use
again voluntary that was arrived at for
a number of different reasons that that
have already been alluded to
um what sort of whatever else is going
on in the harbour so it's quieter in
that area
but also because of the biodiversity
impacts
and the habitat impacts of using them in
other areas and i think
my recollection of why the tour wasn't
chosen is because its importance
the intertidal mud flats for wading
birds in those areas
and the disruption caused by uh jet skis
would be more
impactful in the tour than they would be
in that section of the torridge
i think probably that's me duncher but
there's gonna be something i've missed
okay we'll come back to you if necessary
counselor bushby
uh thank you chair um yeah i'm slightly
torn
um over this over this issue
um but there are a couple of points that
i'd like to make
not ease of use is is is the issue here
because
when ankle park was um was built and the
slipway
constructed and they've made such a good
job of it
um and the ease of use to sue it is so
easy to actually launch one that's
that's why it's so popular i mean
that's the first thing i'd i'd point out
um i mean i
unlike councillor ford i don't go down
on a daily basis and look up
um you know this way in the river but i
do go down there
quite often particularly in the summer a
couple of times a week when i might ride
my motorbike around i'd like to sit up
on the top of the
slip and just watch the jet skis and the
boots and things like that
and sometimes it does get very busy um
that's probably why i like it because
it's
a buzz of activity there um but i can
see that
on occasions how things can get get
out of hand there but what what i'm
concerned about was
i mean if if we said yeah there's a ban
on
on um jet skis how are you going to
enforce the ban
the only way you could do that would be
a physical barrier so if you put a
physical barrier
at the top of the slipway and literally
no one can
reverse a trailer down there and launch
launcher jet ski
surely that same van would apply to
anyone else that was going to be using
uh the slipway to launch a boat to go
fishing
whether or
one of the other activity centers that
are going to use it so you know a band's
a ban on everyone
unless you're going to give certain
people a key to open the barrier to gain
access
etc etc if you do that that could
that could lead to problems uh in itself
um i also like to just touch on
bank end i take the point that councilor
christie mentioned about uh about houses
and noise and things like that but
i think to be honest the houses are far
enough away
um from the slipway not to be
not to be um disturbed by vehicles
actually launching
the noise side of things obviously comes
when they're actually in the river but
you
do get that now and then when they do
come up as far as riverbank house
and go past there um the good thing
about bank
for the last three weeks i've done a
daily walk
um down through the the car park past
riverbank house
and the car park the lower part of the
corporate where the slipway is it's
completely empty
right the launch rate is not used at all
you've got the area that they used to
house the old skate park
um is a fairly large area there's not
there's never a car in there it's
completely empty
so if anyone was launching from there
that would be my favorite if i was
if i personally had one purely because
it's an easy slip way to get down
i take the point about the mud but may
need a bit of clearing off
but once you've done that you've got
everywhere you've got all the room in
the world to park you
your car on your trailer or your van
your 4x4 or whatever it is
without any real issues i don't know why
people have all started to use
capital instead of benefit but you know
as i said right at the start
ease of use is probably something to do
with that you know
i am a bit torn thank you
i'm chair yes lynn
yeah very brief again i'm sorry uh and i
thank you very much for letting me come
in but obviously
not say it's a big issue for me um and
again i've got to remind all counselors
whether it's just absolute or not you're
meant to be unbiased open-minded
and make a judgement what is better for
all um
and just carrying on uh from what
coachella dora uh was saying
it was almost a bit contradictory
because she's on about the environment
i'm all for tourism in fact i would say
to you 99.9
of these users are coming down on a
daily basis not spending a penny
um at the moment they can fire up as
early as um well they do i've seen them
at our five other morning
just don't forget even though i put it
all down have you
all read the report that i've put
forward you've got a hotel there
that spend employing local people and
it's not an exaggeration i think about
three refurbs and seven you
spent over a million pound in the 30
meters
from the slipway 80 meters from the top
now come on come on
there's no comparison this site is is
all about ease
because they don't read the size some of
them are actually launching five and a
half hours
on a small tide after i water making
pits down in the bottom of the slip that
kids would fall in when they're battling
i mean please come down please join me
it's a lovely little village just keep
it lovely thank
you councillor mcgolf
yeah thank you much mr chairman i got a
couple of questions the first question
would be to sean
sean um obviously with a permit system
in place for
jet ski users um
what's the feasibility of this um the
reason why i asked this is if you've got
a permit
then we can actually track it back to a
vehicle at the time so if anybody is
actually
abusing the rules we got some way of
actually managing it
and an implementation of a camera system
dana
instead of a physical barrier because a
physical barrier
would prevent other users using a slip
braid as well
that's my first question should be
someone could you answer that for me
yes of course chair if that's okay um so
so i think the first
point there is that um it's what rules
would we be enforcing
so you could it it there's a voluntary
code of conduct
yestery there aren't bylaws the unsafe
activities out there it would be the
police
who should be enforcing this and not
torridge and so
you might have a different means of
recording who was there
but equally it's really not our place
to step in and manage those on water
issues we don't have the powers to do
that so
so so that's the first thing there um
hope does that answer that one for you
um can i come back yeah
yeah thank you much uh just you know
obviously i want to raise somewhere else
after as well um yeah coming back to
that sean obviously um
as council ford alluded to you know it
is our step way so we do have some
responsibility for our own slipway
so we can't we can't just buy the you
know past the bucks saying is you know
decode the conduct
etc etc because unfortunately the
minority are spoiling it for majority as
always aren't they
yeah yes so that's that that chair is
why we've
um we've sort of tried to suggest in the
report that the only
controls you really have are the
physical launching
uh stopping the physical launching of
jet skis i mean jet skis i think
are the issue and i i think all of this
comes back to the point that
and councillor ford will no doubt
correct me for wrong is that he
doesn't see the value in jet skis they
cause more nuisance than they're worth
they're dangerous and he's very scared
that there's going to be an accident
down there
and he doesn't really want that so he's
saying i think the best way
to uh stop this is to stop the launching
of jet skis
so i mean i've i think i've tried to
summarize there what councillor ford's
concerns are it doesn't want jet skis
operating off of ecuador
okay chairman yeah obviously i've read
the report
and cancer ford's motion and fine detail
he's very passionate what he's putting
forward we've got no response from the
harbormaster about
bank and slipway why haven't we got a
detailed response from our harvard
master abated launching from bank and
slipway
because obviously after council bushby's
um the point he touched on about is it's
hardly ever used and
some of that tourism may be handy for
biddeford considering that it's
unfortunately lost its high shield
regeneration bid anything that brings
tourism into the area
would improve a bit of a tenfold and it
is it is far enough away
from the residential housing there
you know you've got basically the rugby
club there and you
there's there's plenty of room plenty of
distance there but why haven't we got a
detailed report from the harvard master
can i start please
i'm not trying to speak can speak for
the harbour master if you like chair
having spoken to him about the issue
um so the harbour master you know
basically as i said earlier on
is concerned that this this is a very
difficult problem to manage
um jet skis are problematic in every
single
harbor or estuary um
around the peninsula from from paul's
findings
what paul is concerned about is that if
you
just allowed launching from bank end you
would bring
the problems that are described by
councillor ford
to biddeford rather than getting rid of
the problem
and in biddeford you have a range of
different uses going on down here not
least the commercial port activity that
needs to be managed
so it would just be a displacement issue
just displacement of the problem
it is for members to decide whether they
see the value
of the tourism benefits outweigh the
problems associated with jet skis that's
that's entirely your judgment call
chair can i just come up one more please
yes
okay thank you very much we're just
passing it back aren't we
unfortunately you know a decision needs
to be made
going forward you know do we keep it
then epidural can we please it don't
happen or no
we can't please donate but you're saying
it's under the jurisdiction of the
police which are
well underfunded got too much going on
at the moment anyway
i try to get a nice resolve in the
middle happy medium to be honest with
the permit system going forward because
if they paid a
statutory money from the permits that
would then
deter somebody that what abusers are
such
and of the jet seas itself if there's
nice fee put on the jet skis for using
it
that would deter some of the people
little fly boys that are
whizzing up and down the river you know
what why we looked into permanent system
what be the price of a permit system and
also when i touched on about the camera
system down there
i mean the cameras work properly if you
maintain them and it'll actually give
you full details of actually who's using
slippers any one time
i've seen couches before donut early
mornings i've been dating myself i've
seen him doing it not on slipway
just walking around and i've seen it and
i can understand his concerns
about the safety issue of it i mean my
first mind was to keep the jet skis down
on the slipway there itself
fred torres come to some sort of reserve
there for safety issues
but we don't seem to be coming to this
at all so at the moment i'm like-minded
to support councillor
ford's motion
uh yeah briefly because it's important
actually
um because it's evident to me that
perhaps some councils
haven't took the trouble to read
everything because there was actually a
permanent system
if um coach mcgoff chad from uh trevor
jennings i
did copy that into what i said i've read
it a little worried so i've read it
right we did try uh permits mate it
didn't work
all right so it has been tried we won't
be pleased we ain't got resources
let's make this very simple oh much left
to underline
it's our slip way that's the only chance
we've got
of trying to make this problem less bad
i can see the point we can't resource
policing of the river how many times i
need to say that
but i am not how the hell can i sit why
do
you know buy and do nothing because to
compare bitter food with apple
is a forest we've got key jumping
crabbing
thing you even have a world crabbing
contest i mean
obviously to me people haven't got the
time to come down in my beautiful
village
that's fine i understand that i ain't
got the time always to go to um
dalton who's worried winky timbuk2
come down see the problem there's
nowhere near the same as biddeford
council bushby is actually right got
loads of photographs different day
empty car pocket bank i don't
necessarily
want the pushing of biddeford i just
want to deal with what i see
is a very very dangerous position at
appledore and when a kid gets squat in a
minute because i even put in there
about a rib being hit by a jet ski
and the men are straight if you can't
see a rib you're not going to see a
beaver
canoeist paddleboard that's the tourism
i want to attract
the people the paddleboards canoes their
families have a bloody good time
sorry about the language but come on
that's right
chancellor lock
right i'm going to slip my head above
the water here then and i'm going to
propose
the closure of our door slip way for jet
skis
with suitable bollards put position to
enable continued access use
for swimmers and canoeists etc and the
decision with regard to bank end
will be left to the harbour board
do i have a second done yeah i'm happy
to second that
counselor james
is this to be permanent i i was
wondering along the same lines but
do it for 12 months to see how it goes
right well i don't think so because if
you if you
you know make it available again you
could get the same problems recurring so
i would make it permanent
fair enough okay councillor dart
um thanks chair so if we were to close
apple door and put up bollards how is
that gonna
impact on people launching boats because
i i get the jet ski problem
but we're in danger of really
complicating issues
for as is quoted in the report
the various other crafts that use
um the um slipway so
how are we actually going to make it
feasible that
you can launch a boat without these
flipping bollards getting in the way
i just i can't see a way forward that
you can
stop jet skis without impacting on
other um other people who want to use
that slipway
yeah you can't no
um can i come back on that
yes len i did mention earlier you could
restrict it and actually because we
haven't been charging them they've been
putting the trailers everywhere nobody's
been doing them we've probably been
losing income actually
i actually did say earlier that you
could restrict it to a hundred
fifty to a hundred users or whatever and
find a system where they could pay
i could say a hundred pounds for the
privilege because most people in
appledore
and fairness have their own moorings or
whatever as they do in other
places now i understand and we got
some valuable employers around you like
skern
you don't have to have a million uh
people that use it
advertise it or whatever properly and if
people aren't prepared
to pay a hundred year per annum and for
the pleasure of using that facility
don't say it well a lot of them local
from breaking the rules i would actually
pay 100 pounds
and i will reiterate unlike a lot of
councillors i always declare
when i ever have not got the interest on
this i've got no interest i've not owned
a boat
boat it's not about my enjoyment of
whoever i've not been in a boat other
than the ferry
um and uh you know i'm not saying i
don't own a bomb i'm done for five years
okay cheer thank you
right i've got a proposal and a
secondary
and no one else wishing to speak
so i'm going to put councillor locke's
proposal to the vote can you
someone read it out for me please sandra
could counselor lock repeat it please i
did miss
one tiny part i proposed the closure of
abrador slipway the jet skis
with suitable bollard stroke barriers
positioned to enable continued access
for swimmers and canoeists
with the decision for bank end use to be
determined by the harbour board for jet
skis
and that was seconded by councillor
james
have you got it okay sandra yes thank
you chair thank you councillor lark
let's put it to the bottom uh
councillor bushby against
councillor christie oh
councillor dart
i'm gonna have to abstain on the on the
proviso that we haven't accommodated
boat launching so this is not thorough
enough
concept so i abstain
counselor hicks or
counselor james or
counselor laws
cancer laws you're muted
or counsellor lock or
cancel mcgoff four
councillor wiseman against
and councillor craigie four
that's seven four two against and
one abstention chair hold on
thank you very much for your support i
mean it's worried me for a long time
thank you
right that i believe brings us to the
end of the agenda
so i can declare the meeting closed at
11
42 thank you all for your attendance and
thank you for members of the public i
hope you've enjoyed it